hello everybody
welcome back how is the food coma is it
good
great i'm going to talk about something
really really fun and exciting to wake
you guys up and that is monitoring
yeah okay cool hands up if you monitor
your software
okay some of you didn't put your hands
up that really scares me hopefully the
next 30
40 minutes will change your mind and
help you understand why it's really
really cool
this isn't just about monitoring so i've
been in a situation i'm sure you guys
can relate where you go to conference
you hear about some cool new technology
your mind's exploding with buzzwords and
you get back to your office and back to
your desk and you're like
i want to implement all of the things
right now
and you look at the code that you've
already got and the legacy system you're
supporting because somebody left the
company
and all of the things you're trying to
do already and you're like well
how do i get from here to this glorious
new future where all i'm doing is
buzzwords
every single day and this is really kind
of the story of how
we rebuilt our monitoring systems piece
by piece to get to that glorious future
more or less i want to start out by
explaining a little bit of context as to
why i care about monitoring so much
so i work for riot games out of los
angeles we have an office here too
um and i care a lot about games i'm a
gamer
we make a game conveniently
it's called league of legends have you
heard of the game
some people yeah cool that's awesome i
love it when people have heard of it
except a little bit less explaining to
do
so it's a popular game we recently
announced we have 100 million players
monthly
and as a game designer 100 million is is
great right
loads of people playing this thing that
i love and made as a back-end engineer
i hear a hundred million and i think oh
that's a lot of things that can go wrong
and they do right nothing's perfect so
our game is about seven years old
and some key characteristics of it it's
a fairly
strategic game i like to think of it as
action strategy tactics
all rolled into one you grab four other
people mostly
it's 5v5 you carve out an hour of your
time to play and then you play this kind
of big rock paper scissors who's going
to play what who are my friends playing
who are they playing
you get into the game and you spend an
hour making decisions together about
what to do
and because it's so complex people take
it really seriously
it's a sport an esport but it's a sport
right people get paid to play it
i kind of wish that sort of thing had
been around when i was in college
um just like just because there's
professionals playing it
doesn't mean normal people don't take it
seriously too i take it seriously
and you've like spent time trying to get
better at the game get your competitive
ranking up
which is why it really really really
sucks when you lose
and it's not your fault and i don't mean
your teammates are bad
i mean this
i hate this screen something's going
wrong with the servers
right i can't get online i'm in the
middle of a game i'm super hyped up and
something went wrong
and i kind of think of it as my job to
stop this screen happening to help us
fix it when it does happen and stop it
from ever happening again
the players don't like this either they
they really don't like it they make
memes
and youtube video songs about our
servers
and like i've been in a glorious
position where someone's made youtube
videos about a product i worked on and
they were fantastic right they were like
fan videos that's amazing
these are not the kind of videos i want
about things that i work on
this is not my legacy i'm reading too
much hamilton
um so what happens behind the scenes
when this sort of stuff happens right
so we have a network operations center
this is nasa
but it's basically the same thing like
i'm not allowed to show photos of arnock
but basically the same thing
and that's a room full of people 26 24 7
around the globe
and their job is to like detect respond
to incidents escalate fix
things what do they need
information they can't just sit there
and guess they're not psychic i wish
they were sometimes but they're not
and so they need information and that's
where monitoring comes in
we need to enable the network operations
folks to do their job
and ideally do it with a minimal
disruption and minimal like escalating
to the wrong people at four in the
morning
which can happen so
the question i like to think my job is
answering every day is how do we
reliably monitor stuff at scale
and i'm going to break that down a
little bit seems like a simple question
right
it's kind of complex in places
i highlight the word reliably because
we've been in this wonderful position
where
if the monitoring systems aren't
completely reliable
why do you even have them what's the
point like you can't trust them then you
just
resort to spamming the forum refresh and
hope no one's complaining
if they're like 80 of the time available
and 100 reliable that 80
i guess they could kind of work but the
real job is to try and get like 100
believability
in the monitoring systems otherwise you
end up with things like the monetary
team getting paged first
because the folks receiving the alert
don't realize that they don't know if
it's a real alert or not
it's like is your system working or is
this real
so reliability number one monitoring
that's what this talk is about what is
monitoring
i like to think of it as three layers
you've got
basic systems monitoring cpu
ram disk space network usage the kind of
bread and butter of like the metal
hardware that you're running on and if
you're starting from scratch like that's
the first stuff you do
the next layer application monitoring
and this is more fun right is my
application even running
maybe not if it is running how's it
doing is it doing all right
is are there some warning signs is are
things starting to trend the wrong way
is it behaving badly are there error
rates are there response times
and so you can think of this as like the
skeleton outside the app like response
times
error logs what's going on less about
the interior logic
because so that to me that is the
business intelligence section
and when you talk about a game you get
some really fun questions here right
who's playing what champion
are they winning too much are they
losing too much
are people talking in chat about lag too
much can we detect things like
like network lag just from what people
are saying in game
spoiler we can it's pretty cool there's
also things like
who's logging on from where who's buying
stuff is this normal
is this abnormal and as soon as you get
into those kinds of questions
you start going back to the network
operations you're like hey this is stuff
the knox should probably care about
if nobody's logging in and we're
expecting peak traffic and it's not
there
that's a live issue that's just not
something you wait for an ecl job and a
tableau report
that's something i care about right now
and i'm trying to fix and so these lines
are kind of blurry
and i'll get into a little bit of how we
deal with that later
the third part is scale so
games companies have different
definitions of scale and i come from
tech industry where
like vastly varying definitions of scale
so i wanted to
color this in a little bit to us scale
is having a bunch of data centers
physical data centers bunch of metal in
those data centers
a lot of things running on that metal
and then
just for monitoring alone a lot of
metrics hundred thousand
individual data points per second being
sent
obviously this isn't where we started
this is a rough
estimate of where we are today and this
is nothing in comparison to like our
business intelligence pipeline itself
this is just the standard monitoring
pipeline
and again when i see these kinds of
numbers as an engineer i get really
scared
especially when the word this has to be
reliable is highlighted in the front of
my vision right
these are some some pretty annoying
numbers to try and keep up
and so it's kind of the story of how do
we get there
so life without monitoring is glorious
right everything's fine you can't see
the fire you don't know it's there it's
it's perfect
so maybe you start out here you're a
startup or something you're like oh i
don't need monitoring it's fine they're
going to tell us if it's broken
um and you you deal with this for a
while and then you think okay
what's the most basic stuff i can do i'm
getting a bit concerned about not having
anything
so you add network disk ram
cpu standard stuff and then maybe you're
like okay i want a bit more than that
because you know that doesn't tell me
much about what's actually running maybe
you add stuff like
port checks right it's like responding
on a specific port
that to me is like monitoring 101 if you
don't have that then you're not
monitoring anything really
and the problem with stuff like that in
terms of delivering a game as an online
experience
is if it's not responding it's dead
something's already broken and it's too
late to do much about it but
reboot it and hope it works so you need
more complexity than that to try and get
ahead of the problem and anticipate
incidents before they actually start
hurting people's competitive experience
so you google monitoring how do i
and you find an off-the-shelf monitoring
agent we did this a few years
back i'm not going to talk about the
specific one we used
because it's kind of irrelevant to this
story and i don't want to make it the
bad guy
it was it does monitoring stuff and it
does it pretty well
you end up with something that you
install on every single machine and it
runs a bunch of checks for you
it pushes it to a data store we have one
in every data center
it's a monitoring service so it has
things like alerting and dashboards and
visualization built in
that's lovely we realized that in the
network operation center we don't want
to open a tab for every data center
especially as we add more and more data
centers so we add something global on
top of that
just a little cache keeps track of the
alerts that are currently going off
gives them a dashboard here's everything
that's a problem right now and
everybody's happy
right so happy there's unicorns
and rainbows and everything is lovely
and nothing ever goes wrong
well not quite so one of the issues with
this system
is i need to know what's on the machine
to tell it what to check
so we're very tied to things like
knowing what is on a specific piece of
hardware
what role that hardware has in our
ecosystem and as we move towards the
future that's not really a world we live
in anymore
let's face it a few other drawbacks
we have a very diverse ecosystem our
philosophy on
stack and software is do what you like
we'll figure it out
so we have like almost every i hate to
say here every programming language
because i know there's going to be some
you guys work on that i've never even
heard of but we have a lot of different
programming languages in our stack
and as a result you end up having the
monitoring team in the middle
connecting the agent on the box to the
thing that's running
right you teach it how to talk to java
apps you teach you how to talk to
databases you teach you how to talk to
very specific
random stuff that random teams build and
that monetary team becomes a huge
bottleneck
they have to be subject matter experts
in basically everything
and they have to keep up and they get
paid when stuff breaks because nobody
knows who it really belongs to they're
the only ones that really understand it
you end up with this blurry line between
health and business intelligence
and the main thing that happens there is
you have lots and arguments
because say we write a database
monitoring check and part of that check
is
are the number of transactions being
processed in the database
a healthy number is it greater than zero
so that becomes business intelligence
because hey i kind of want to know how
many transactions we're processing
an hour in the store or whatever well
can i keep that for like a year
can i keep that for like five years well
no we're going to keep it for a week
because we just care about alerts and
debugging
and live response but i want to keep it
for a year so you get these
horrible arguments and it's also like
it's a monitoring system
so some things that it doesn't do i
think we started today we use something
like prometheus some of these things
would not be true
but they're true for the one we chose
things like we installed it at the data
center level
so you can't get a global view without
adding more stuff things like
predictive alerting trends regression
stuff like that not built in
so you have to add our own and we end up
having to like add them in the
connecting blue which is a little bit
awkward for us
things like it's a polling based system
so every n seconds we get a data point
so we get samples what's the problem
with samples
they hide a lot of things they hide
spikes they hide anomalies
they tell you like useful things for
like memory and disk perhaps but they
really don't give you everything you
need
so we try and solve these problems now
having said all this the thing worked
pretty well
like we got monitoring that we didn't
have before we are no longer the this is
fine dog
we have some information and the network
operation folks are really happy because
they suddenly have all this visibility
so this approach wasn't bad it just
wasn't enough
and something happened to kind of
evolve this for us
microservices i love this so talking
with buzzwords right
microservices or as we kind of call them
just services
just maybe a little smaller so we
started moving more and more towards
this microservice
ecosystem our engineering organization
grew
we added more stacks more languages and
we end up in a case
where one team just can't own monitoring
we don't want monitoring to be their job
we want it to be everybody's job
this is sneakily a sort of culture talk
about how do you change that
how do you get people on board with
thinking about something they don't
really care about
it's tough it's very tough
so there's two things that we can do
kind of a hint on the screen
so we get people to change their minds
we get people to care about monitoring
and not just leave it
for some people to clean up after them
and we change the data store data
pipeline
to actually a data pipeline rather than
a monitoring pipeline
we look at things like the blurred lines
we look at things like how people want
to use this data
and we say well maybe monitoring isn't
special after all
maybe we can just use the same stuff we
use for our big data
which one do we do first well one is
pretty easy i think
changing our technology is not too hard
changing people's minds
that's impossible or nearly impossible
so we did that first
just in case it failed i guess
and we basically took a step back and
said okay we've got a micro service
ecosystem on our hands
how do we make this thing a really
healthy productive micro service
like environment for developers how do
we get developers
all speaking the same language rather
than being in a room or shouting at top
volume
across each other
and there's three steps to that first
one is interoperability
contracts so it seems kind of obvious
when you look at it
you basically agree for everyone to talk
the same way to each other
have a common language a common way of
exposing data
we came up with a spec called ambassador
i love the name
so i'm going to mention it and the idea
is if i'm a service
i have to expose these kinds of
endpoints we agreed on http and json
as our common like format for
interchange
form format for apis and transferring
data and some of you might think
oh http and json oh i've got a favorite
thing like protobuf or grpc or soap
that's better than that why didn't you
choose that
this does come around time and time
again but fundamentally i learned from
this a really interesting lesson which
is
it doesn't matter what you agree on it
matters way way way more that you agree
on something
and not everyone's going to be on board
with it from day one but the
thing that you create by being on the
same page is so much more powerful
than having some rogue bursting off
using protobuf in a corner by themselves
so we have these endpoints they expose
json and the idea is
i just put them in my app and i will be
part of this ecosystem
we make this easier of course we create
frameworks for common languages that
have these things out of the box we
integrate with koda hail metrics
libraries and various ports of that
library
making it really really easy for me to
get metrics in my app
from the moment i start writing it and
things like the status endpoint give us
that for free
as well it's effective report check but
it gives us a lot more information
all perfect right well not quite
one thing i learned from this experience
is it doesn't just matter what you
specify it matters what you don't
and the stuff around the edges so you
say
http json some services
use https i don't know which ones i
always go to the wrong url and i realize
oh it's an https and have to go back and
change
it so that's kind of annoying but it is
what it is
another interesting thing is we say you
have to expose these endpoints we don't
say where they have to be
so i could have whatever i like as the
preceding url path
and that leads to some fun moments when
you're debugging you're like how can i
remember where this one is
now we do say you have to give us a way
to expose them in a common way that we
can find them
and so here's my little plug the swagger
i love swagger
swagger is a great way of turning
basically json into a web page and then
you can interact with api endpoints
and we use this pretty heavily so we
have a guarantee that if you're in our
microservice ecosystem i can go to your
swagger
and find you and use you which is great
another interesting thing is
authentication authorization how do you
lock down
things not standardized yet working on
it
but it's one of those things around the
edges that we didn't quite specify
quickly enough
so i have to try and remember does this
one use an api key this one uses ssl
certificate this one uses a token it's
kind of fun
all right so we speak the same language
that's great but
we're also moving towards this world
where i'm not just a service on a box
this box is not just a database server
well that was a poor example it probably
is
um this box does a bunch of things in
our like back end
how do i find out what's on that box how
do i find out what's running
kind of bread and butter of micro
service ecosystems
you guys are very familiar with these
two things but i want to mention them
service discovery so i love it we use a
protocol based on netflix's eureka
and the idea is i register a bunch of
stuff as part of my metadata i specify
where is my ambassador
api so we can find that easily and we
have standardized on how you name
yourself and how you identify your
location
that makes it super easy to like
interact with stuff and find it and know
what it is
there's one problem though
so i need to register with service
discovery
but i need to find out where it is but
if i don't know where service discovery
is how can i discover service discovery
to register with service discovery
we use dns we take a format of your
location
uh turn it into a text record query it
tells you where they are
of course that means the dns has to work
and you'd be surprised that's not
always the case especially when you're
standing up whole new data center a
whole new shard
so that's fun so there's always going to
be some dependencies turtles all the way
down you just get to choose which
turtles at the bottom i guess
the other thing that i find really
really helpful for metrics especially
this dynamic configuration we have
what's effectively a global key value
store
that's all it is and we key based on
location
application name and version put key
values in
get them back out it is as simple as it
sounds
we use git and jenkins to push stuff in
because that gives us a lot of cool
stuff for free
like auditing like pull requests
reversion
is great why do i care about this so
much for monitoring
this is more like application stuff now
it allows us to turn things on and off
dynamically turn on and off alerts
change thresholds
and if you're debugging a live issue and
you want more metrics
and you've kind of turned them off
because you don't want to send a bunch
of stuff you never look at
if you have to redeploy your service to
add new stuff
that redeploy might well fix the issue
itself because software is software and
sometimes turning off and on again does
actually do the trick
so you want to be able to like keep
things as close to the problem state as
possible
while giving yourself more debugging
information and dynamic configuration is
one way to do that
of course if there's a problem with your
dynamic configuration code then you're
kind of stuck but that stuff's really
hard in the metal tested in our
ecosystem
so i love this stuff
so we have a bunch of services we don't
care where they are because we have
discovery
we know that we can talk to them a
specific way hopefully you guys have put
these two things together a little bit
and the next piece will come somewhat
obvious
i have a box i have some agents on the
box
and my agents talk to service discovery
and then talk to the metrics endpoint
now i could have skipped aside and made
things a little obfuscated and simpler
but we do local discovery on the box
why why don't we just use central
service discovery
two reasons as a games company we
sometimes have the kind of services that
are somewhat ephemeral
for example a game server that lasts the
moment people are in the game and
is torn down when people end the game we
don't necessarily want those things to
be discoverable in service discovery
we want them to stay fairly isolated
onto the box they're on
we also find that this gives us very
natural sharding and scaling
because if we have a central discovery
and a central metrics agent
then we need to figure out how to
partition the space of services to
scrape for metrics
this means we don't have to solve that
problem yet so that's nice
and then once we get in the box we just
look at the slash metrics endpoint
there's also a metrics metadata endpoint
that defines alerts
as a service owner i control that i can
put what i like in there
looks like this it's just json we
learned that
if you say hey developer you have to
specify the schema here and
register with this registry here and do
all these things to get your metrics
they probably just won't or they'll come
to you and make you do it for them
and we don't want that because that
sucks so
just json works pretty well for us
and we changed our pipeline the only
thing we changed is the box in red
we keep the rest the same this is
important this is the change in the
engine in flight aspect
because we don't want to retrain a bunch
of people on how to use stuff
we don't want to have a whole lot of new
untested code while we're running a live
service
and people aren't going to add their
ambassador endpoints overnight
so we have to keep running the old stuff
while we're also running the new stuff
we overload the same protocol that
monitoring service is using
so we insert into the same data store we
kind of impersonate it and look like
the same kind of data and we realize
this isn't enough
we need more global services at this
point
so we build a full global cache index
layer that looks at everything in every
data center
and we use grafana on top of that to
give us dashboarding
and give us much more powerful tools
while still keeping
ninety percent of our stuff exactly the
same as it was and gradually
showing developers hey you exposed this
metrics endpoint this magic thing will
happen
you'll be in this dashboard
what does that look like i want to show
this graph because i love it when people
have pictures and not words and also
because it kind of illustrates the point
this uses the same pipeline he's still
running today we haven't finished
changing the engine in flight yet
and you get the ability to see hey this
thing's spiking i did this change it
stops biking
that's great so it's not just instant
response but it's also health monitoring
on
ongoing basis did my stuff change you
get some interesting things like
we started shipping more bytes huh
i didn't realize that number was low
until i noticed that it went up after we
did some stuff
and now i realize that's low so
monitoring is this ongoing thing of like
you don't always know what's healthy
looks like
and having a lot of data in a lot of
dashboards gives us that color
and picture and it helps us give us a
tool to communicate
between various stakeholders right the
network operation center the service
developers themselves
even product owners and management all
those people they love
tools like graphs they tell stories so
we're not perfect yet in fact we only
changed one thing to a tick
which is sad so we we deal with the
biggest problem
ecosystem diversity we get rid of a
bottleneck dependency
and you know being on the monetary team
is kind of cool now because you're
building this platform that's a generic
thing that everyone's using
you're not the after for janitors trying
to get monitoring in at the last minute
but if anything we make the second point
here worse
because i'm a developer i can put
whatever i like in my metrics i'm going
to put all the stuff i care about
and that's both health stuff and like
business intelligence logic-y stuff
who's playing what games at what time
and i get really sad because i want to
keep that for years and i can't
a good example of when we ran into this
is we moved our entire game server data
center
from the west coast to chicago
to make sure that players on the east
coast had better latency
and we used a lot of the metrics that we
had around that to capacity plan
to see the effect of the move but if we
are thinking about monitoring as
something that's really ephemeral
it's just data that sends off alerts and
then we throw it away we couldn't have
done that
so what happens we've run into scaling
issues my favorite thing because we're
putting more and more things
in the system we have to scale it more
and
the monitoring systems start bottling
out they're like they can't keep up
with one service developer launched a
service without really telling us
and i think the service launched about
500 metrics
on every single machine in every single
data center all at once
and that to us was a significant
percentage of our traffic
and like monitoring back-end started
going crazy it's like holy [ __ ] i've got
all this new stuff and i can't keep up
what's going on
and we didn't even know because he
hadn't told us he didn't have to he just
had to expose slash metrics and it all
worked
so we had a communication mismatch of
hey if you're going to do this you
should probably tell us so we can get
ready for it and add more capacity
but we didn't have that and instead we
had to scramble to keep up
we also end up writing these tools
around the data centers
and again we can't do things like
prediction or trends or alerting
we have to try and get the data out
somehow we run my sequel scripts to get
data and run
predictions on it it's pretty messy
and it ends up making making application
developers have to take
on some of that work they have to start
recording rates they have to start
recording spikes themselves
and exposing those into the metrics
pipeline which kind of sucks
so that's where we go on to the next
step change the back end out use a data
back end not a monitoring specific back
end
everything's going to be lovely we hope
so we change the pipeline again we keep
the left hand side the same this time
well mostly we get rid of the data
center level of storage
thank goodness finally with a global
store because this is 2016 and we can do
that now
and we use a bunch of things that are
kind of battle tested for scale
for much more scale than we need we use
elasticsearch for our store we use kafka
to get stuff into it
our event collector is very dumb it's
really just a buffering
measure so that if we have issues
between data center and global
we can keep on like keep onto data
without having to
drop it on the floor and we use http to
get stuff in because that's our
agreed-upon protocol
this works pretty well but of course our
metrics agent does have to speak
learn how to speak http so we have a
little change there
we get a whole bunch of stuff from the
switch to a big data backend
like dashboard and cabana grafana
alerting using elasticsearch
that we didn't previously have we do
have to retrain people
now now we keep graffana the same so
that looks mostly the same
but kibana is a whole new kind of fish
but we didn't have to retrain them on
everything at once we just retrain them
on this one thing
so how we doing oh looking good oh
not quite there this is yellow it
doesn't quite show up
um because we're using a database
a big data based solution right we can
do things like
determine whether something's a metric
or not we can change retention periods
even access policies
um we can provide a lot of tools because
elasticsearch has a lot of tools for
interacting with the data and doing
things like prediction and trends and
stuff
rates just built in statistics are there
we get a global view but we are still
polling because we didn't change the
metric station out yet
one piece at a time and polling isn't
perfect and as
everything else gets better the flaws
with what you already have become more
and more apparent right
so we're still polling what do we do
we rewrite the metrics agent too we
sneakily can do this at the same time
because we have to change it to http
anyway we start like moving more pieces
out
why rather than just update it why do we
totally rewrite it we actually rewrote
it in go
because we wanted to make it really
really fast really resilient
go concurrency and buffering give us
really really good tools out the box for
doing this
we can move really fast with the code we
can make it super simple and it works
with our cross-platform diverse
ecosystem
we can also share the code effectively
so we end up writing something that's
just
a tool for pushing batches of metrics to
our collector
so why does that need to be an agent
well it doesn't right it's basically a
library
so we go back to our development
frameworks where they originally
launched and said hey guys use these
you'll get your api endpoints for free
now we put the metric stuff in there too
we'll say hey use these you can send
your metrics however whenever you like
and we get rid of the problem where
you're like snapshotting your metric
inside your code and then the agent
comes along a minute later and picks up
a really stale piece of data and then
sends it
because you're in control so we move to
push-based metrics and eventually
we don't even need the agent at all to
kind of make ourselves obsolete
so there's some caveats here
first is that we haven't finished doing
this yet because when you have a system
that works
the resistance to changing it can be
pretty high
because it works why do you care
like why should i as a stakeholder care
about funding a team of engineers to go
solve this problem
so you can end up with a wonderful
hybrid ecosystem where you have some of
the really old
version some of the second old version
some of the new version all running
together
and you have to work really hard to
deprecate it and that's kind of where
we're at now and that's our focus is
just deprecating stuff
we have to make sure that things that
don't have those api endpoints built in
have a way to talk in the new system so
we build a bunch of side cars we
call them to wrap around an existing
service and provide those api endpoints
and health checks built in
one of the things that was mentioned
yesterday is that
just because you have metrics doesn't
mean you have the right metrics
it's what you don't measure that's
normally what the thing you want to look
at right you get paged it's four in the
morning something's broken
oh i wish i'd tracked that thing no i
don't have it
so just because you have metrics doesn't
mean
you're measuring the right things and so
that's why we ended up with a system
that made it really easy for people to
add new stuff in
and that has to be really important you
have to think about who is your customer
what are they going to need to do and
how do you make life as easy as possible
for them
the second caveat is that
people have different levels of
standards and perfectionism and people
have different levels of caring about
stuff like metrics
so if i care a lot about metrics and
i've put loads of stuff in my app and
loads of alerts and all sorts of things
i'm probably going to get the page
because my software's complaining
even though it's a piece of dependency
three hops down the line that's actually
broken
and you end up with this wonderful micro
service fun time
where you're trying to figure out what
is actually broken just because your
service
has some error going off and the best
way to deal with that is to
like look at your architecture look at
your dependencies and see if you can at
least alert
like with relevant information about
what's broken not just my service is
broken but
my service is broken because it can't
talk to this one because this thing's
not here
but it's definitely something that you
have to work really hard as a culture to
align around
let's get ourselves all caring about
this stuff all having the same standard
of alerting
and make sure that you know just because
your dependency has alerts doesn't mean
that they're people who are on call on
on vacation this week
so you have to go on the same page about
standards of response times and slas
and all that stuff that as an engineer
you kind of try and let someone else
handle for you
but you do have to start talking about
it
but fundamentally changing this thing
piece by piece helped us focus on what's
important to us
helping make sure that developers
started changing their minds caring
about monitoring
and making sure that we didn't have some
team that was just doing it for them
and making sure the network operation
center had the tools to respond to
things
and that means like my life as an
engineer working and monitoring
is a lot more fun than it would have
been two years ago when we didn't have
any of this stuff
and it gives us a chance to hopefully
the metric i care about most is the
number of youtube videos being created
about my product
and i think it's going down i should get
some hard data on that
fundamentally you can't change
everything overnight
and monitoring is awesome those are the
two things i wanted to say today
thank you guys